what are you getting in your tattoo
right now okay on this hand I'm getting
uh Rocky and zavi which are our
dogs a you're a doggy yeah our two dogs
are they cuz did you get a tattoo of
your postumus dog your past my baby boy
his name was ero we lost him during Co
and he was the best dog ever um and so I
got his name tattooed on the same hand
that's why I put him like there's
something about a relationship that has
no words it's very special and dogs are
healers they're you know why they say I
have an emotional support dog all dogs
are emotional support dogs and I have a
theory that people who don't like dogs
are just deeply wounded and when you
notice like dogs love people that don't
like
dogs it's like horses and dogs are like
that's what they do they like help
people we have a story actually coming
up in the news we're going to do the
news together together I can't wait Drew
news I love Drew new oh my
God I'm so happy to do Drew's news oh my
God Joel you are validating my reality
when we were trying to launch the show I
was like it's news but it's like good
news but it's real news it's not like
satirical and comical it's like the good
things that are happening in the world
that are really existing like you know
just good news I I have a story for you
though really yeah
you I I started uh I was I wanted to
have I wanted to talk to people because
I love talking to artists I just and
I've been doing it for two decades you
know music artists that are trying to
make it ones that have and you have
produced incredible artists we've been
able to work with some really amazing
artists like you and benj are no joke
like well we're lucky to work with great
artists even Ink Masters I get to be
around great artists great tattoo artist
so I just love artists John's a great
artist what
is the weird weirdest tattoo anyone ever
requested the weirdest I don't think
I've ever done anything that was too
weird what about
placement placement yeah you done any
weird body parts I've done very private
body part tattoos oh my God like what
like all the way as low as you can get
to the
goods like um is it true that you
actually tattooed someone that we're all
obsessed with his name right might rhyme
with like meat
havenon yes so crazy story I tattooed
Pete Davidson Miley cyers Chris red all
backstage in Pete's dressing room no way
oh my God what was that Vibe like the
vibe was so chill so relaxed and I'm
like I could like hear Miley performing
and then right after she came in and
like the full outfit like hey like
tattoo me in my leg like yes get one get
one on yeah let's do it so it was so
cool such a good experience that is such
a thank you for br transporting me to
that dressing room and moment cuz I
wasn't there but in my fantasies I can
now visit
[Music]
it